Adam Jones is head of Passenger
operations and services at Gatwick
Airport a very good morning to you thank
you for joining us now this is just the
first day of striking action by border
force staff only working one day now
between now and New Year's Eve how much
disruption are you expecting at Gatwick
well I've just come from the border
where everything's working smoothly with
the contingent staff in place we expect
passport checks to take a bit longer and
we do anticipate some disruption but
flights are operating normally arrivals
and departures and we expect that to
continue
and who are Manning the booze at
passport control at Gatwick today
so there are border force staff who are
not striking members of the Armed Forces
and volunteers from across the home
office who have been trained to operate
the Border we also have the 25 e-gates
in each terminal they're operating
normally for those of the biometric
passport
[Music]
training um
to take care of passport control
you'd need to ask border force that who
operate the Border they've been
conducting the training and the
familiarization but their staff are on
the border right now and it's operating
smoothly
and how concerned are you about the
delays uh what information do you have
for passengers in terms of who will be
most affected during these strikes
so at really busy periods we think the
disruption May extend to up to two hours
at the border just at the peak times
um as I said anyone who can use egates
is advised to use them it's the quickest
way across the border we will have extra
Gatwick staff in Immigration Halls
helping people get to the right desks or
the e-gate and also providing welfare
support to any passengers who are having
to wait for extended periods and which
passengers are able to use those e-gates
and which ones we'll have to cue
yes so anyone with a biometric symbol on
their passport the passport holder has
to be 12 years or over and the people
from the UK EU countries America Canada
Australia New Zealand and a few other
countries are able to use them and our
concierge staff and immigration Hall
will Point those people to the e-gates
then get across the border as quickly as
possible
there's most disruption going to impact
past
impound
to the UK what about passengers also
departing on flights over the next few
days are they going to have to leave
extra time as well
you know we expect no impact on
departing batteries at all or those
arriving into the airport from other UK
airports the Republic of Ireland the
Channel Islands or the Isle of Man
uh just give us a sense of how big this
disruption could be at Gatwick and
across other airports in the UK
so today is the first day of the strike
so we'll really find out how it works
today as I said we do advise passengers
to be ready for queuing it could be up
to two hours so please be prepared bring
some food and water ask our staff if you
need any assistance but we are confident
the airport will operate as normal and
flights will arrive and depart on time
now is there a risk that airports like
Gatwick could be forced to close during
these strikes and what would be your
message to the unions and to the
government
so we absolutely see no risk of the
airport shutting the board will remain
open it is resourced by the contingency
staff and we have plans in place if
queuing gets excessive just to control
the amount of traffic coming into the
airport
in terms of the strike itself we just
encourage all the parts involved to
reach a resolution as soon as possible